all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 48 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got a very special guest Xbox game
pass cloud compute gaming and can ant
them avoid destiny curse to discuss so
we gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who in my opinion
offers some of the most passionate and
brutally honest perspectives in this
entire gaming community while some may
be intimidated by her conviction on
sensitive topics this lady always backs
up some points with logic in his
fearless in exposing the hypocrisy
introducing the leader of the Lucca
holic movement the audience [ __ ] your
hilarious and fun-loving personalities
in the game making her debut into the
realm of the Lords my girl lady are you
doing everything good yeah things are
great I'm really looking forward to the
show today I think we're gonna have a
good time absolutely we go have some fun
okay so we are my co-host with the cold
most as far as the usual suspects at the
roundtable he is missing today but I
think he's got that that new gig so your
money's training well so we will miss
Lord addict but of course we have
returning our most technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives with a single
player selfish experience
offline profile back online this week
[Laughter]
what's going on guys Mac man great to be
back home first and foremost I want to
say thank you to you guys from my party
for my wife for the for all the good
wishes we were on our way to the airport
when the show came on last week and I
put it on and she when she heard that
like she was she was really touched it's
actually really really appreciative Matt
absolutely man like I said condolences
to the family you know I'm going about
to go through it in about two weeks
myself you know it older and you know
family members you start losing people
and you know you just want to kind of
reflect on the positive you know this is
the first family situation we've gone
through as a couple really like honestly
I can't I can't say that my marriage is
bummer it's been fantastic so this is
like the first kind of like hard family
situation and it's one of those things
like I didn't know her grandmother that
well not really well at all because she
sees had Alzheimer's for a long time so
I've never had a relationship with her
or her with me let me say one thing in
that right there before I die I would
like to catch Alzheimer's this is crazy
and this is messed up no it's not
because those people are because you
know I got a situation going on right
now and we have a grandfather who has
Alzheimer's but he is in the most
utopias state like he's in a state of
bliss where the outside distractions
aren't no more weighing upon them um so
it kind of freed them up from all the
shackles that was you know then we put
on through life and baggages through
life so hopefully how Alzheimer's were
a situation where it's a nightmare
situation and it's a blissful situation
it's one of the situations where like
what hurts most is for the family when
she doesn't recognize many more things
here that sort of stuff is the thing
about Alzheimer's is that in the long
term what it does is like your brain
doesn't react to you to your body the
way it should so after a while I stopped
sending the proper messages to your body
like hello you need to you need to chew
you need to swallow that's the problem
you know and ultimately it wasn't the
Alzheimer's that took her but um but I
tell you man when you're there for
family members that are hurting and you
see them in pain that isn't oh my lord
that's me well I got a coming up - the
guy got a big trip with my grandparents
glad to have you back in like I say your
spirits up Lord so that's good and of
course we had the excess gamer oh the
lord of combat sports who is a man of
his convictions and demands nothing less
than that premium experience Oh beloved
Lord King how you doing sir we're doing
fantastic everybody we are back it's
Sunday and it's fantastic yo check this
out last night we had the UFC popping
off and we have boxing poppin off now
this is kind of different from the
Showtime boxing okay Showtime boxing
puts together competitive competitive
matches where each person has a chance
of East combat and has a chance to win
said match but HBO does their thing a
little bit different in boxing we have
these things called tomato cans right
else people that you do not know that's
in there with a person that you do know
and the tomato can is set up where he
isn't metal lose another tomato can
might give you one or two rounds
anybody's gonna give you one or two
round what the tomato can might get
blasted out tomato can is supposed to
beat
we have both scenarios yesterday where
one tomato can got blasted out and one
tomato can last into the distance this
is HBO's crap at its finest this is
stuff that I will never tell you to tune
into this is the reason why combat
sports in fighting in general has gotten
a bad name oh you watch that fight in my
house and I remember jumping into your
arms
we were like the minority of people who
could actually beat Mike Tyson times
Mike Tyson was so feared like you just
didn't go against like just believe in
knowing that your guy could do it he
didn't at that time hold if it was
towards the end his career yeah you know
people like oh he definitely watched now
like this gonna be easy pickings for
Mike and he did it your fork feel I'll
never forget that's why it's sovereign
is clowning me because I did probably
jump up we was dancing around in each
other arm actually actually it's three
okay it's one at the bobble ooh yes Bob
we had de la hoya vs. Trinidad
everybody know that was sweet pea
that was sweet pea vs. De La Hoya and
the probable Trinidad Trinidad
that was an inverse versus De La Hoya
those people in their house wanted to
put a gun i hating to us was the Mike
Tyson absolutely oh and we can't forget
Oscar De La Hoya vs Julio Cesar Chavez
and that big movie that we you know we
almost got killed that reckless when it
comes to combats was what we people we
get behind our people during the fight
okay so listen Lucas Matisse a vs2 made
a can a and we had Jorge Linares versus
tomato can beat so let's go with the
under car first the Jorge Linares versus
the the tomato can be tomato can be goes
the distance with Jorge Linares Jorge
Linares boxes his ears off and another
masterful arm you fight they're trying
to set up that and Loma chinko mama
trickles gonna move up he's targeting
that belt and they gotta get those guys
together no Lucas Matisse a got his
knockout and he was supposed to get to
knockout over these overmatched poor
guys from these third-world countries
that I don't think that should be
fighting for round fighters you know so
shout out to HBO for showing you how
it's not supposed to be done before
don't you Showtime showed you the
fighters and they set up they fighting
this for the year for the first half of
the year and it was nothing but
competitive bouts um if if I'm going to
tell you to boycott something cuz I saw
Monique telling people to boycott
Netflix
I will not be boycotting Nexus ma'am um
but little people like on HBO's uh yes
on the boxing those there were two
knockdowns by him t say they were just
like they it was so disc one of them was
a push he pushed him and he fell under
the ropes and he was done and I said
what he did wasn't a punch I was like no
be happening this can't be happening and
then the other knockdown the other
knockdown you hit him with it with a
left hook he got hit with a return left
hook and then when he said just corn
went a glancing right he flew is very
suspect like what happens that you have
one great week and then you have this
rollercoaster ride boxing I'm so tired
but when you look at it real quick so uh
what happened will you have C last night
well you'll see I wasn't paying too much
attention to all the other cards but I
was paying attention to the main event
which was I was busy playing a shadow of
war so so daiquiri souza against Derek
Brunson
Jacare has something approved because he
got his head pinched off by Robert
Whittaker his last time out he had
beaten Derek Brunson before and
Strikeforce knocked him out Brunson and
has been kind of Brunton been kind of on
on low little trajectory lately eight
billion they've told him yeah he needs
to be less aggressive and be more
patient in the ring in it and it kind of
goes against his whole style yeah and I
think yeah he wanted to be patient
against Jack ray he didn't defend his
head properly decorate caught him with a
crescent kick to the cheek that boy head
off cream was gone and Jack ray just
pounced how the highlight look like his
body betrayed him
a little like someone I did like he was
good setup card and when also her we
have Daniel Cormier gonna is gonna fight
that's good news for UFC this week sorry
about HBO boxing Lord kick you love said
about that wasn't that Showtime realness
we don't get back to these gays real
quick so best
kognito here spreading that gaming
realness on the ILP not telling you what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear so before we get into what the
Lords are playing lady loca a video game
system history what led her to create
that great YouTube channel and of course
being a member of the incredible RDX
podcast so lady Lucan let's start with
your video game system is like what was
the first game systems you had kind of
gets you into gaming so you know I
mostly played on handhelds when I was
younger and this is something I say
quite often is that I didn't start
gaming regularly like hardcore quotation
marks until this generation actually but
my mom hadn't I seen SNES and then I had
a Gamecube I had um Game Boy Advance
game boy color Game Boy SP DS 3d SBS XL
like all those stuff and I just gained
here and there I had a ps2 a ps3 and
then like I said it wasn't until this
generation where I was really started
getting invested in gaming in gaming on
a console and I'm really into a
single-player story driven game so I've
been having a blast um huge fan of Mass
Effect Dragon Age culture yram just
dropping heavy hitters like I just threw
out some bombshells yeah those are some
really amazing games and like I said I
love story driven games there
in my opinion nice so you pretty much
came up I was also like in the Nintendo
ecosystem exclusively I would say like
from handheld and then kind of like to
SNES is where you kind of started it
okay so let me actually cause a lot of
lords here we were saying it guys we're
all there's a lot of good people to chat
today Nessa
all right cool so then we transition
there and then now as far as like the
current generation of systems that are
now did you or did you end up going
straight into the PlayStation from the
SNES like where did you go after that
and that point your journey so I had and
then my brother had an xbox 360's so any
games I wanted to play I would just play
on his system but you know since I had
playstation credibly okay I have a
PlayStation 3 I'll get a PlayStation 4
he's probably gonna get the Xbox one it
was just kind of that thing right and
then um two years ago like in the 2016 I
picked up an Xbox for that Skyrim
remaster with mods yes I started looking
around for Xbox news cuz you know
something I noticed is like whoa a lot
of people seem to be down on xbox like I
get it they messed up and I've heard
some things here and there I wasn't like
super invested and then what's going on
in terms of the gaming news so I started
looking around and I looked up like Xbox
news and stuff and Xbox nation popped up
and said okay this is what is this it's
like I didn't know that YouTube had
podcast like that it's like okay let me
just click on this why is it two hours
it's kind of weird but okay this is
actually kind of interesting and I
started continued listening and then I
moved on to UM console corner and then
be GST and the C morning's crossfire and
I just listened to all those shows and
then
you know when mucho craps started doing
NC and it was like oh people can call in
I was it oh that's kind of cool let me
call in yeah ever since then it's just
kind of been a roller coaster you know
they heard me people were like is that a
girl
I can't tell she wolf picked me up for
one of her podcast and ever since then
I've just been going on other people
shows doing different shells and it's
been pretty amazing the community like I
said there's a lot of them there's a lot
of BS in the community but there's a lot
of really amazing people who have
accepted me with open arms who have been
kind to me who have elevated me who've
pushed me up and it was because of them
that I started my youtube channel cuz I
I didn't have any interest in it but
it's just kind of like I'm on Twitter
pretty much every day
saying my views saying hey guys perhaps
Jasha calm down it's not the community
gets really worked up about stuff that
really doesn't matter and it's kind of
like personally I'm not really
emotionally attached to either of the
consoles
you know they just entertainment for me
and I'm not like I know I get um this is
like a new thing going on but apparently
I'm the queen of X pots that's like the
new designated you the Queen I think
it's uh guilty by association because I
hang out with a lot of really hardcore
Xbox dudes and it's just kind of like
well she's cool with them so clearly
she's an X pot I'm like oh that's fine I
mean if you want to call me that that's
whatever it's not like a big deal to me
because it's just some made-up term in a
really miniscule community you know what
I mean absolutely but this man it's been
a really good time I like I said I've
met so many people I've been on so many
shows and I'm grateful that you asked me
to be on here today absolutely one of
the se young voices in the game would
love your takes on a lot of stuff I
first of all if you're not following the
ashen Luke on Twitter you got a problem
it is late but she definitely offer some
great perspectives and on you make a lot
of people think you challenged him to
kind of get out their comfort zone and I
respected that sussan you know and I
seen you obviously we had deal on the
show before and
J Fonzarelli dam had like almost three
thirds of the two thirds of you let you
call it two fifths of the RDX so I just
felt it was it was it was right you know
we talked about it for a little bit and
yeah I was gonna ask you about the next
step as far as your progression in
reference to RDX specifically because
you know obviously a huge fan of those
guys we've had a lot of those guys on
the show and how did that happen how did
that come to be you guys like that so
okay so I I never really talked to
dealer that much um I actually started
talking to him after he asked me to be
on the show but what had happened was I
was a guest on xbox nation crap he
needed some people to fill in because
she wolf in cheek a B had to miss and I
look okay sure I'll help you out because
uh crap is one of my best friends I like
love that guy and I know he gets a he
gets a lot of [ __ ] I guess but he has
always been kind to me he's always been
respectful yeah even though you know me
and him have different views when it
comes to a lot of stuff in the community
it's like I would never attack him for
anything that personally absolutely I
don't care so he asked me to be on Starz
on Xbox nation and I remember it was K
mega K mega was talking about how he was
like oh I don't understand there doesn't
need to be an option for 60 frames for
the X and I you know cuz casuals don't
care about 60 and I was just like hey
man I get that however it's like this
console and this is what Phil said
because this consoles for the hardcore
so we should have an option and the next
day dealer was like you know I like that
you were able to challenge him to offer
two different perspective because you're
my show I want it to be different
perspective I want people to be open and
honest and not with the fanboy [ __ ]
so come on I'm like all right cool I was
like yeah definitely and RDX has been
really amazing the community like I said
cuz dealers side of the community like
the people that he has none of them knew
who I was and I you know when I first
started I got a lot of [ __ ] and I don't
know why I don't know it's just kind of
like I don't get it really I mean it's
maybe people are just aren't used to
hearing like a loud outspoken I got a la
I got a lot of BS people kept saying I
kick her off she suck
I'm like wow it's really not that big of
a deal and then I'm like one day that
that troll top dog was like bothering me
in the chat so I just went off on him
cuz you know I have this habit of going
off on people when they irritate me
never since then they've been like yeah
she can say we respect that shout the
lone agree yes we you know the language
police is here we go just to see that
whole progression so you kind of got off
into those franchises before I can
answer you say Mass Effect you had yet
Skyrim a well give me give me fill out
that five of your like top five gaming
franchises of all time alright so like I
said Mass Effect Dragon Age yeah really
into The Witcher I played The Witcher 3
that game was phenomenal actually one of
the best games I've ever played in my
entire life honestly like I was shocked
by how good it was because like I was
like wow okay and then I've been like
playing a different whole bunch of
different RPGs and a lot of shooters as
well as I've integrated myself in
Exmouth community because I didn't
really play a lot of multiplayer games
but I also I'm a huge fan of the Saints
Row series Saints Row 2 in particular
question
the Ashton Lucas oh is that is that a
Dark Souls where we at with the name
that's all yes it is a Dark Souls
reference Scotty I'm a huge huge Souls
fan of really big advocate for those
games um they're amazing in my opinion I
a lot of people don't like them for some
reason probably difficulty but I think
they're great and I would advise people
to just try it out because you know it's
it's tough but fair and I know a lot of
people like that's like the thing it's
like oh it's tough but fair but it
really is cuz I was I had no interest in
the game at all and
I was like you know what I'm gonna give
it a shot I'm gonna give it a shot
mostly just cuz I was watching this dude
on YouTube and he was trash I'm
definitely better than him let me just
like let me try this out love love the
background love that gaming history so
uh we gonna move on as far as what the
laws have been playing this week so late
look or what have you actually been
touching this week what's been what's
been in you so I've been playing a lot
of persona 5 really good RPG and then I
pick oil I picked up someone gifted me
Monster Hunter shoutout to biggie you
rock I picked up Dragonball Z fighters
with my gay partners things I've been
cycling through nice for free yes that's
fantastic
[Music]
let's go I haven't played here but I
picked it up Celeste that game that we
talked about in the Nintendo Direct mini
came out and it's like I can give it a
ten and a lot of outlets are giving it a
really high score so I was really like I
said I have to pick this up in I haven't
touched it yet but it seems like it's
one of those really you know hard as
hell old platformers would like a cool
something like The Meat Boy bean and on
the console side I've been playing that
Dragon Ball which is again if you love
to show you have any sort of nostalgia
for the show get this game you're
running the best representation of that
in video game form ever
Lord sovereign is it any pitfalls to the
game I wouldn't say
see my take on it is its it is it is
casualized enough especially for an Arc
System Works games it's usually very
deep it's casual eyes enough where your
kids can grab it like hit a couple
buttons on the controller and some nice
explosions and nice stuff habits on the
screen and you can have fun playing it
but I've seen some some some higher
level play and it's all about like
understanding what cancels what out what
defeats this just like any fighting game
just poker purposes are up exactly and
so the higher level play there's there's
some stuff going on definitely it's it's
so it has surprising deaths to it so
yeah I guess I'll talk more about that
as I continue to play Oh finally I
finally beat Wolfenstein hmm you ahead
of me yeah finding people to stand out I
was crazy
fantastic game um I finally saw credits
and Forza horizon 3 Wow mmm once you
finished all the soul cases what your
physical cases you see credits fighting
this plenty more to do and then I
finally played a little more origins
sasses Creed and I got back into shadow
is Rob gave idiot II oh there we go
actually in command it is to this day
you're right on that game now we
definitely wrapping it hard Lord King
what have you been playing sweet um well
let's start off with the game I put in I
said Leon let me complete this game and
get it going and nothing really
transpired from that with shadow of war
I don't know what's going on is it
disconnect me with me with the game the
first game there wasn't a disconnect
that was actually flowing with it so I
Magister I guess it's so much I got a
professor of games so I'm trying to get
back into that game um destiny of course
everybody knows that it is
too much of it when it comes to shadow
war they just double down on all the
stuff that was great about this this is
so much you kind of get lost in the mix
mmm
yes of course and that's my problem with
certain games certain games when you
throw too much at somebody it really
takes away from the main story and you
know whoa don't let me go over him do
this and make this war happen oh wait a
second that guy and then he get
distracted he lost like two hours doing
that you did the story oh then you know
destiny of course guys I had to do my
night falls and my stuff like that big
on 30th that's what I'm waiting for
and back to Lucca with I'm loving the
fact that somebody gifted her the game
of the world what I did was I realized
oh my god muscle the world is out I'm
sorry and I have brought it for I'm the
3ds now when I bought it for the 3ds I
thought the limitations of the system's
force certain things to happen because
you know is it's really a Nintendo type
of thing so Nintendo has a lot of
fail-safes going through right that's a
Nintendo stuff so that's when I saw the
game and III I didn't want to play it I
said you know what I saw it on the
screen I said it's open-world it's gonna
be yes yes yes and not a lot of nose no
nose and it looks great and it's gonna
be great and so automatically I plucked
down my 69 I got the digital edition you
know I wanted to get the best boom put
it in just yes let's go
what's up with these graphics oh all
right zero rising dawn horizon zero dawn
typographic soak a little washed out so
I'm winning the colors boosted colors up
to ten took that brightness down a
little bit then I mess with the have
three molds graphic frame rate and
resolution resolution X options right
yes of course the X if you're not
playing on X you need to step it up
anyway
extra booze yeah that's right don't
don't be mad at me cuz I'm bad but okay
so I'm like all right let me get into
this game let me make this happen
hold up wait a second it's like I'm
playing the giant 3ds game okay why is
all these checkpoints there's no drop in
and play type of feature now what I do
like what they're doing is the character
that you make he's in every cutscene he
looks like he belongs you know like some
cutscenes that you've made a character
you look like he don't belong but here's
the question did you did you I see a cat
out is you can't ice they could have
took away the cat and gave me an
open-world game like they said why does
really yes exactly why does this say
monster hunter world when you and
monster hunter are apartment 8 home okay
so man Lord addict and I decided to play
a game together
it was the most combos some Nintendo
crap going oh you know Nintendo dude
hold up the wait for this guy to meet
you in the lobby now both of y'all press
the button at the same time oh he's been
kicked because he kicked the button
first and you're supposed to wait what
and then when you actually get into the
world
it's a lobby it's not an open world it's
a space as a place space a play area
okay you can't not transverse the world
and get from point A to point B no you
can play in this Lobby that you see that
is populated with animals do not be
fooled this is not an open world game if
you want an open world game I suggest
you spend your dollars else where the
craft stability of the game is beautiful
the RPG aspects of the game is nice the
trapping and the hunting is great when
you're in there with your friends it's
nice that's gonna be a nice aspect to it
but do not buy this game looking for
grand theft auto
the world 9n graphic readers you ain't
said the games look awesome buddy I said
look he said looks washed out and he's
running on resolution so he definitely
yes issue with yes yes it's remember
it's a texture thing okay so they have a
lot of textures going in so when you put
a lot of textures in something has to
lose when you lose that you start to
lose in a saturation of the colors
saturation of the colors look completely
washed out it doesn't look as vibrant as
a ton of games you have it's not your
television is not your system it's that
game okay good
because you know how disgusting we were
with the Wii U version when we thought
we were gonna be jumping into it and
then we just both fell off of it very
quickly so is it is it inviting at at
least in terms of the systems is it
inviting for a new player to come in and
be able to kind of wrap their head
around that stuff or is it you know
obtuse this is just that overwhelming a
smorgasbord of things to do with
limitations and they say in two games
grant they got a graphics move on X so
like why they don't boost the graphic
did you hear me say colors the colors
are washed out the graphics being no
particle effects a little water
reflection I did not say anything like
that
did I yeah okay yeah so you want to go
to apartment one or apartment to and you
gotta take the lift to get up there can
you meet Stan do you have to get to
another load screen
oh you food have you been playing games
or not is it an open world or is it what
is it but it's not don't act like it's
not a buffet table with limitations like
hole up you can't eat that shrimp right
now you got to eat that shrimp later I
thought this was a buff faith no right
now we serving chicken and that's down
over here so you got to eat that chicken
for
before you can get over here whoa what
you have to do is wish somebody gave it
to me for free my friends this is
playing it and I'm trying to give this
game its proper due because I always
wanted to be about it but I see the
limitations and people's mind that they
say you know what this is great and they
want to be sheep
I'm not sheep sorry um this is not
captivating this is not what I'm used to
over here I'm used to open-world games
if you wanna say open world let's do it
not just about MIT stuff okay so you
have mid-range weapons you have
long-distance weapons and you have short
distance weapons right you have to pick
the weapon that actually works to your
gaming type
all right so dude close in combat dude I
get that type of weapon you know quick
fast double swords type of thing
Lord addict like said that's what he was
using I like to use a range type of
weapon you know to hit the animals from
a distance so I can dodge get enough
time um and it works well that way in
the actual combat and taking down an
animal it's fun you can have a good time
with it what I'm saying is is the fact
that the world is in the predetermined
type of state you start beating the
animal up a little bit he be like hold
on let's dip let's take it over to this
predetermined area over here and he'll
start running and you can't really do
damage on the animal or if you on his
back hitting him he'll wait till you get
to the specific area you do more damage
there it's quick question King is it
broken up by like you think by like
damage level like when you get him down
to a certain level Denise oh okay so
it's almost like kind of mini scripted
events kind of thing so okay and it's a
Nintendo thing if you guys a deep in
Nintendo's world and if you played any
of the monster hunters if this is your
first monster hunter um that you're
sitting here like wow this is a crate
but then you start looking at the
limitations that I said without being
biased to it you might really like the
game it might have been your only $60
and you trying to validate your purchase
but it was my only $60 and I'm not
trying to validate this purchase
thank you for your monthly only chance
to play once but I tried the solo [ __ ]
jet purposely because I wanted to
experience to see how it gets now is it
truly fun sale going on you know had
little stuff going on drinking the coke
Crowsnest figure stuff out and then I
found the island or something if some
skeletons in there did a little treasure
hunt whatever but I didn't know I guess
I dropped the Inca but I don't know I
did something wrong or all I know is
like the game went to this very like
dark music I'm like what's going on
there's nobody attacking me was going on
and I look and I'm like why is my ship
sinking I did figure that part out so
I'll play for a little bit of that but I
did have fun got to do it again this
weekend obviously with the Lords you
know get everybody in that's in the beta
and get the 4 million kind of team
experience cuz I'm hearing that Slade
like a lot of people are having fun with
that so I want to see what that's about
but earlier pressure so far we're good
um do some pub G you know last night
shot the monkey punch I missed your
message we definitely had a good for man
going on North Falcon and all that
oh sorry I gotta give a shout-out to
monkey punch because every time I'm in
monkey punch isn't my thing
yes shot at the monkey punch and ah yeah
we tried to get a cook I came closer a
couple of chicken dinners you know I'm
saying didn't put them away but we have
fun with that and as you know I'm still
on that switch playing that wild game
this is the police faster hundred days
now more racial charge foolishness in
this case
you know that game have like a and it
seems like you've been putting the hours
in
I've been blazing hard like I'm getting
to work but uh real todo like it really
is fun but I did actually because one
investigation I got stuck I had the
Google I cannot figure this I got it was
going on and during that time of me
trying to cheat and figure out what was
going on oh yeah I realized that I'm at
the third act of the game so I'm almost
done so I'm like where I mess up
it's been fun I having a great time with
it trying to get wet on we gonna move on
so um yeah last yes is our ILP results
are in the people have spoken to the
question with the recent announcements
rumors and Xbox with a map OTP first
party games digital game rumors how
excited are we regarding the future of
the Xbox brain the winner at 83% in our
most lopsided three-way ILP poll this
year is the hype the future is bright
for Xbox group coming in at second place
at only 13 percent was the Sony is way
ahead too little too late group and
coming in a third was the team shadows
at 4% they don't care lab Oh out sells
them all what do you think about this
whole first of all anyone hyping that
int in the lab oh I'm gonna need you to
UM that's the most PC way I could say it
y'all need to cut it out but you know
when the game pass stuff came out most
people were excited for it the most the
majority I could see and honestly it's
like we're getting closer and closer to
a
Digital future and that's just something
that people that have to accept now it's
easier for me I'm a millennial I didn't
grow up in this all physical all the
time but it's just gonna wake just I
mean you got to get with the times and I
think they're gonna ease people into it
and like I said I think it's we're a
long way off before physical is done
completely because if you think of it
like this there's still CDs and they're
still DVDs even though most people watch
that critics and Hulu and most people
get all their music from streaming
services valid points valid absolute
words the Lord's got anything else on
this poll regarding the future of Xbox
and so my wife is gonna be home at about
20-30 minutes and she helped groceries I
would not be much of a Lord if I didn't
help her by 10 minutes all shut the
camera down and oh absolutely what's
your perspective on things perspectives
you guys know this it is wonderful to be
back with the Lords and the lady as well
it's nice to meet you hi nice to meet
you as well
please kid I didn't I didn't mean to
interrupt please continue Lord saw he
was saying about the the poll that we
ran with the excited about the recent
announcement the grown men will do it
like oh here we go
so I like you know I'm a big PlayStation
and you know Nintendo guy and it is
allowable for me no I have no personal
interest in it but then again I like a
lot of games that people tell me John
you shouldn't like that because you're
gonna thought I like Kirby I like you
know I like I started starting into
Pokemon because my ten-year-old and you
know people tell me these things and I
said well you know what one of us has
been to war and seen combat one of us
has it hasn't so Oliver I like and and
if you want to tell me that I'm I'm
trying to curse by the way guys you know
me thank you know I appreciate you
trying to channel my inner Jim Ryun
freedom but uh you know it's not for me
but I'll tell you what my son my he's
almost 10 years old mm-hmm he got a
switch for Christmas because I'm awesome
and and he is incredibly stoked about
the level so you know I'm not gonna sit
here and tell people that yeah I will
never tell you what you can or you know
forget that I'm not gonna tell you what
you should or shouldn't be excited about
because it takes you know it takes all
types to make the world go round
you know I personally think that the
game past is a bigger deal for the
industry as a whole
um I think the Nintendo Wabo will be a
fun diversion I think it's gonna sell
incredibly well um I think it's gonna
blow the doors off it's it's not for
everybody but but Nintendo fans do this
right and I've been guilty of in the
past too you know in the Tenno says
we've got and I not spend a drop in ever
do so my herds I'd be you know so yeah
um we did this with the January 11th
direct right um so I did the mini direct
I mean it was I mean recent era was
going nuts and Nintendo was fueling the
fire they you know retweeted a picture
of chibi-robo burning yeah other
companies I can't cover getting into it
and but you know we do this to ourselves
um I think the game past is a much
bigger deal we go get it we gonna get
into it cuz little kings are up next but
definitely oh no cool cool
so we gonna get this show rolling
everybody's been hinting at a this
announcement obviously that the big one
and went down so lord King
would you like to set this thing off for
the roundtable I told you from day one
he plays chess not checkers everybody
wanted this all brute force mentality he
didn't have a brute force cachet
when it came to what he was able to do
in Microsoft they when I'm gonna prove
itself or what literally he had he took
his pieces and he went to work he
started building strategic alliances and
he started making things happen what he
does what I like to do is like to take
narratives away from individuals so they
can stop saying certain things because
when you can stop saying power power
power hmm then that dismisses your
conversation and your attitude towards
me so you took away the power a
narrative from Sony boom okay um
what's next Oh y'all don't have games
and the games well we do have this thing
called game passes $10 a month and let
me tell you something if I give my kid
100 games at $10 a month I'm winning
here
all right um the service pays for itself
and that was a great service in itself
of what people were saying about it was
no real great games inside of it and it
was a lot of 360 games that I noticed in
them take away that argument from
individuals because that was true um it
was a lot of pass games and they had
some new games in there what they
decided to do and what was in Jesus was
all first party games were permanently
d-day to date on release released in
game Pass you said that doesn't make any
sense how are they gonna sustaining
south-south well they will sustain
himself is selling life they will
sustain itself in selling game pass
subscriptions as $60 a pop the game stop
has just started selling them at em gay
Pass has arose in the subscription from
the announcement
now it wasn't like you said see if these
came out yet because I was gonna
purchase their game I don't have to
purchase their game no more I got my
game pass now you have to fundamentally
start looking at the way that games will
start to be distributed if Microsoft
becomes the next Netflix right because
this is kind of like the way they're
going my thing is they need one or two
big developers to say you know what
we're gonna join you in that game past
thing we can prove you right if the
numbers bear fruit right as far as how
much a percentage that these guys can
get let's say 2k 18 or 19 well number
the arrow it comes out day to date on
game path is that a game-changer for
sports fans yes if the next big RPG
comes out day to date free in-game pass
and Microsoft can secure this isn't that
a bigger announcement then then oh god
if war comes out on April 20th for 60
bucks we know what's coming out for 60
bucks it's in 1999 is a free and
PlayStation now though is not any news
but news is free games they told you now
you have free games I want to know if
how do the Lords feel going into this
new digital future because death that's
completely on some real digital ish
mm-hmm how do you feel about this and is
Microsoft on the path to becoming the
next Netflix or Amazon gaming yeah let's
get the lady in let's get the lady in
see how she feel but once the game pass
announcement was me lady look how do you
feel about it well I think you know when
I first was announced my first thought
was oh this is really funny cuz he
effectively killed a portion of the
console war because you can't talk about
sales of games for xbox anymore because
they're all gonna be coming out on game
pass so I said okay but that's really
funny to me my second thought was man
the fanboys are
yeah definitely on both sides of the
fence I've heard people say whoa Xbox
games are only worth $10 I'm like wow
you sound really stupid like I just
think it's a great value for all of us
and personally as long as I can play the
games I'm I don't really care where they
are my only I guess I can understand the
only way I can understand it is if
people are like right and Xbox is
getting ready to not be in the console
space anymore it's no real competition
for PlayStation and thus we as the
consumer suffer in that in but other
than that this is like a great value for
all of us and I honestly think that
people who are upset about it they're
either in denial about the fact that
we're getting closer to it is you know
age or they're just fanboys much more
material and more ammo for this no I
brought you in because I know you a
shout out to Lord rap you guys had a it
was a brat rant that went on and you got
had Matt piscatella on a couple times
and broke some things down so I know you
have some interesting person so yeah so
now I think you can honestly say and
although I think there's positives and
negatives to this right to be honest we
don't know enough about any of it in my
opinion anyway to say whether or not
this is going to be ultimately a great
thing for Microsoft growth a bad thing I
think there are a lot of positives not
just for Microsoft but for the industry
as a whole now you have you have a major
selling point for every single console
now with the PlayStation 4 I don't think
anybody would argue that they have this
generation anyway and had the largest
most diverse stable of first parties
closes I'm so I don't think anybody
would argue that I Nintendo has the
portability and the convenience of the
of the switch
I've got one it's a just a wonderful
little device and of course you know you
know
Mario's although I mean it's this was I
mean they killed it this year I mean
talk about games to watch your console
with absolutely and then now with Xbox
you have what is probably the looking
anyway to be the best value in in gaming
um you know with game paths you know and
and and if it I'm not convinced that all
of their first pretty exclusives will
stay on gay paths for an extended or
forever obviously they made a statement
recently de Burgh yeah and they did
actually they got in front of it I was
shocked
they got in front of it maybe statements
today that the first party games will
permanently remain in Greenburgh kevanna
said yeah that's interesting right so a
lot of the negative a lot of the
negatives I have heard is that well you
know well two of them one this is going
to cause Microsoft to go you know to
turn Xbox into a services and post a
platform I don't necessarily see that as
negative
um because because the the money that
Microsoft makes it's the same for Sony
and it's the same for Nintendo they make
money on sales of games not sales of
consoles um the ps4 is the only console
that is sold at a profit but it's a very
meager profit they don't know and I know
for a fact that Microsoft is taking
losses on the Xbox one as in the Xbox 1x
um the meat potatoes of revenue in the
gaming industry is games and that's
where I think this could be a
double-edged sword for Microsoft I think
it's going to each other we look at what
it did to social media um everybody was
talking about game that it's all it's
still all anybody's talking on this gave
has and and and how Microsoft is
possibly moving the industry forward
having said that I wonder about the
pushback from first party developers
like Rare who are owned by Microsoft but
are not part and parcel of Microsoft and
what this might do to sales at games at
frickin board of registers and I can't
imagine that stores like Amazon and game
stock and Best Buy will be very thrilled
with a move like this so then one
company a one one store said they no
longer sell the next boxes yeah
no takers I think there's a lot of
hyperbole on going around on all sides
about this and honestly I I like to sit
back and wait before you know I mean I
was I used to be an investigator so I
like to sit back and wait for all the
facts before I make a determination with
something that's what we're gonna do
here I think it's I think it could be a
really really good thing I don't think
it's gonna be a really really bad thing
but I I think there can be some
potential pitfalls for microscope we can
see approach no you do not have an xbox
one honestly I'll tell you this much I
feel more compelled to buy an xbox now
that I have I mean I'm talking to
somebody who built this job I split my
time on the seventh generation between
the ps3 and xbox 360
I don't commit this from the you know I
just I have some I've got a limited
amount of funding and I've there are so
many games to play that I don't know if
I could sustain a third console but this
if anything would push me to get an Xbox
one right now this would be a kiss on
the face of it and it does sound like an
incredible value I just I need to I
think everybody would benefit from from
waiting and seeing what the end game is
gonna be although I will end on this
because I've talked about too much I
told somebody somebody said I can't
believe Microsoft is stupid enough to do
this and I will make this point
companies don't do this unless they
there are metrics that go into this
there early surveys to go to this time
off go to this mm-hmm companies don't do
this unless they are confident that the
product is going to see look at the
switch people you know before I watched
people said they are crazy to project 10
million sales in the first year that's
that's that's that's insane and I said
they you don't throw numbers out like
that if you don't think you can hit them
Absalom these are based on things and
numbers and metrics that none of us are
privy to so Microsoft is confident
that's probably enough for me you pretty
much nailed my for you but of a guess
awfully low so what
but always gate man first of all big
shout-out to rappin and EJ and B money a
hands a little mask until I was on there
this past week show
mattress Katella
of course mega that was on there we and
I touched upon this my my bottom line on
this is that it's absolutely
game-changing um and like- said that
there are some caveats to it that
microsoft and it has to play out in the
in the market and see what's gonna
happen i think the big thing is that now
what it does with their first party
stuff is that it allows more eyes to be
on it allows more hands to be on it now
people who would have would not have
given these games a second look saying
well you know what for 10 bucks a month
why not what it does and what it does is
it just gives it gives the brands more
recognition um in terms of the effect
that can have on on physical sales yeah
I mean it's gonna it's gonna Matt made
it clear that there were things that
that this type of exposure for a game
has always shown that it affects sales
of the game proper positively whether
their sales at the $60 price point I
don't know probably sales down the line
again with the assumption that certain
games are gonna be leaving the service
um I don't I don't know if this game
past offer discount for games in in the
service ya know right before it's about
to leave do you want to purchase this
game at a discounted price yes correct
so on that sort of stuff I think in the
long term again the main thing is for
the brand to get positive recognition
and I think overall and in the long term
it's gonna be it's gonna be a positive
thing for all Xbox first party stuff
moving forward I will say this I will
there's uh if you don't mind if it
doesn't go poof I might I don't think
this is gonna solve all of Microsoft's
problems
I certainly think that I mean Phil
Spencer has done a fantastic job of
writing the ship love had they not so
and had he not done what he did a couple
years ago to
you start the course correction I don't
think we'd be having the constant
conversation but Xbox we are right now
create um having said that they do have
a first party exclusive problem and I
would have told you the beginning this
generation I don't think first pretty
exclusive sell consoles the way they
used to I think I'm wrong now um I think
it's clear that I was wrong about that
and I I'm still concerned about what
they've got on the slate for for 2018
and these I mean I mean there are it
looks better see if these he's gotten a
great reception I think you know state
of decay to looks very interesting to me
I love zombie stuff I think I might look
I think crackdown 3 is there gonna be a
huge dud it is not presented well we
still haven't seen the multiplayer and
this thing supposed to launch the spring
but having said that markers I mean it's
a great start for Microsoft they've got
to get their first party stable under
control though yeah I think if you look
at the new co sales the first party game
right now you look at the amount of
consoles in the wild you say wow this
game should have sold more instead of
how many consoles so that that's part of
the argument well sometimes these
exclusives don't sell but what the
exclusives although they don't sell as
well as they should but the exclusives
what they do is they create an identity
for that console absent that more than
anything is what people identify with
that's what they say you know what God
of War is associated with Sony um see
what Sony like they whatever the sales
may be in the long term it creates an
identity that people latch on to and I
mean that's and I think I think that's
what Microsoft has had trouble getting
like you know I was specifically called
it like a mascot but you know Master
Chief has lost this kind of a shadow
right he's been holding down the ship by
itself locking in that just didn't go
right plant
yeah your mascot it's gonna be blowback
from that nobody wants to hear you're
gonna get rid of an icon nobody wants
you let me jump in right quick I mean I
think like I said Lourdes and me and
lady making some great points I think
this is also a professor let's just get
it down to a pure value perspective
right for the
Summa let's not worry about Microsoft's
pockets for a second from a value
proposition
this is ridiculous like ten dollars
you're getting a vast library of games
and you're getting you know first party
Microsoft games at release that's huge
right what I was also looking at was
that I felt when four made some tweets
recently and he was talking about
single-player focus and losing game pass
as a kind of a jumpstart for that and I
believe a couple people asked him that
you know you know like hey Phil do you
see like this the opportunity to
introduce unique in new experiences to
users and he basically said both and he
was just saying that um he said that he
sees this as a new model that can open
up a lot of opportunities for single
player games and he said he knows that
that model has done well for TV you know
referencing netflix and so off and so
forth and then he also referenced ìokay
which is what believe is a christian
from ID at Xbox team and on trying to
use that as a kind of a springboard like
to lead you know their single player and
have Xbox game packs turn into that
model for studios as that goal you know
so I thought that was very promising
these are stuff loss of them he's kind
of been hinting before you know as far
as what we didn't know the roadmap on
how he was gonna get there until he
revealed exactly it's a lot more viable
to do things that you understand is that
it's difficult to invest an immense
amount of money into a game that's gonna
be 15 20 hours long and you know that
people may not go back to its I mean
it's a hard sell so I know Sony's been
doing it and I've been doing it very
well for a very long time but to be
perfectly frank and I and I love those
games but the fact of the matter is in
the long term it is difficult to justify
sustaining that we're net in that same
way it's just it's very it's very
handsome and then the big news let's
break it down from a Microsoft first
party perspective like let's buy every
cut like you said soft every console has
its identity right Sony has those great
single-player immersive you know let me
saw the God of War trailer right but
like when you look at Marcus off like
look at something like see if these
right they tend to their best games and
the ecosystem tented multi player folk
and what I feel with game pass is that
that actually could benefit them like
look at something that's like if they're
putting out quality first party titles
with kind of a multiplayer focus not
that they won't have any single player
but that kind of benefits that ecosystem
because if one person hasn't like hey I
can just try this out and now we're all
playing these because of a game pass
subscription you know I mean everything
and then the long game is what I'm
looking at like in order for this to
sustain they have to continually put out
quality first party content but also
space it so that you know cuz let's be
honest lady look we know some people go
finesse this system right gonna be like
I'm picking it up right around so if you
make that commitment well let's say
every other month or every month there's
some kind of major release that kind of
gets you to you know hold on and let's
be honest like even with Netflix and
some like EA access some services
they're banking on the fact that people
not either 10 forget it I've done it
before like I've had access and I didn't
really utilize every aspect of it maybe
like you know when the new game comes
out and I want that you know five day
early trial of Mass Effect Andromeda you
know before the month I'm not really oh
yeah I keep forgetting the unsubscribe
exactly just consistent revenue so again
this is something also to look at now I
want to bring it back too late looking
reference before our finish up King is
on in reference to the Austrian retailer
who came out and said Xbox is banned
from our stores no longer you know what
did you feel about that lady look-alike
where were you at when you heard about
this announcement from ocean retailer
game where well one of my friends sent
it to me in the DM and I was a calm as
interesting but it's to be expected
now I know a lot of people are just
making fun of it cuz it's like oh who is
this guy he's irrelevant and all that
stuff but I would like to say that if a
smaller retailer can do it let's just
stop the bigger retailers from doing it
I know that they have like deals in
place in regards to that but it's just
something to keep in mind something to
consider that
maybe maybe they'll make it so they're
not directly violating any contract but
it'll make it harder for people to see
the Xbox consoles in the stores yeah
it's just something to consider it could
happen you always want to keep that in
mind but like this guy I don't know who
he is so I don't care but it's just kind
of like you know you know Microsoft or
you know the Xbox tends to perform much
better stateside than it does
internationally I don't you know I I
don't I don't see any of the major any
any of the major US corporations doing
this I mean when I heard about that you
guys ever seen tombstone oh yeah so
there's a scene in the movie where you
know curly bill is sitting on the porch
and you know Wyatt Earp's brother has
died and he says I wanted to be over now
and and curly bill really summed it up
for me when I heard about what this
Austrian chain was doing this is pretty
much it right here I just you know
people are putting way too much talking
not fit because I I do think I do think
there's something that nobody else is
considered is the fact that in order for
this to be a success if you're going to
put all your first reading into them
they need to be good they need to be
plump yes absolutely dad that ties back
into the problem I think Microsoft has
had this more so 2017 than any other
year at this generation is that a little
bit you know I mean if all you've got if
see if see if the TV is great
yeah it's state of decay - okay
crackdown 3 I don't think it's going to
perform all I don't think it's gonna be
a good game so if that's all you've got
aside from Forza I think that's a
problem okay in relation to trying to
get people out of gatehouse yeah well
you know the games that they do have at
least for me personally I am willing
more willing to try them out now that
it's like not 60 because let me tell you
the no offense but see if these looks
like trashy so let us crack down see ya
you know everybody honest did you see it
has loved see if these I I don't care
because I don't I don't like mmo's I'm
not an MMO I'm a huge fan of fantasy fan
and I've played about 30 minutes of
Final Fantasy 14 and said not four
not not for me that's not to say you
know I understand it's very popular yeah
I agree with look I don't know if see if
these yes it was very highly viewed on
twitch right like it blew it away i
twitch that does not translate to
millions upon millions but millions of
units sold I think I'm taking a
wait-and-see on that one yeah I'm
looking you wanna finish up your topic
okay so the free advertisement for the
one store that said yo I'm not gonna
carry the system no more I can't believe
they did this it was like who is that
guy the hits on the website I'm glad
you're taking a stance man you're
standing well that was great for him I
mean I think this was he took
opportunity he said you know what I'm
going for it I'm gonna ban these guys
and I'm gonna get all these Jews and
Xbox brand does not do well in Europe
like it they obviously weren't selling a
lot I guarantee you so it was an easy
move to make I guarantee you that if
Sony introduces the game fast just like
this one intend no does they sit in a
hole but somebody else then you know
dude will have this um on two physical
copies okay I want you guys to take the
khakis off and put the tiki torches back
in the corner I want you to know this
that you are safe you are safe the world
is not going to change overnight on you
I know some people have dated caps I
know some people are afraid of our DRM
um you guys that are afraid that
Microsoft is gonna hit a switch and say
you play not today to this I give you a
giant hug um I had a guy on Twitter I
forgot your name
but I know you're listening to me
because you are my follower now you are
my slave oh wow I want him to know that
physical is still around physical won't
go anywhere for the next 10 well five to
ten years we're improving rapidly once
we get data caps removed and once we
allowed high-speed broadband to be
introduced all across the world which is
not we got to take away the whole
feeling of superiority where we're able
to download ten gigs in five minutes
where other people can't they take a day
um Microsoft will not stop selling
physical copies of games okay so don't
be afraid of that don't be afraid of
game pass don't be afraid of trying new
things it's there for you to give you
value if you see the value in something
what I will always tell you was to try
it
have you seen the value in PlayStation
now try it if you see the value in most
of us getting a Playstation that's
that's pretty funny yeah I say we felt
Microsoft blew it out the water with
this announcement obviously there is
some concerns but um for the most part
you know it's so pro consumer and it's
good to see the mostly positive reaction
and just to see how this thing moves
forward so last note sorry for no Phil
did say that they're investing heavy on
first party games yes that alone should
allow you to say I think I might have to
look at this game past because nothing
this man has said has not been true he's
been saying truth bags
that's very true I just won't point out
everybody remembers the greatest games
lineup in xbox history Oh shots fired
it was certain words that was left out
what he did saying you didn't hear the
undercut of the words this is the
greatest games lineup in history under
my leadership
[Laughter]
mega Tim said you know we don't have
these numbers from Microsoft in front of
us they're looking at the metrics
they're looking at they know what they
are capable of and they're taking it
they're taking a small small risk on it
no doubt but they've got to be confident
in what they're seeing you know and at
the end of the day it's all about
engagement they want you in that
ecosystem you know you got the xbox live
subscription you got the game pass
subscription you know once you get in
there they're banking on you sting I'm
also sure that if if games do take a
drop in physical and digital downloads
I'm talking full price stuff in response
to the game pests I am sure Microsoft is
going to pay these first party
developers a stipend um to make up for
that so I mean I think we all sin you
didn't can you also need it and the only
ones who can do something like that yeah
absolutely absolutely
so lord serve now we uh finished up this
we're gonna transition over to you
what's going on in the world of cloud
what's going on in the mighty cloud
what's happening so so my topic actually
segues perfectly from kings topic
because what I want to know is right
with Microsoft obviously going the route
of services with the Xbox brand right
there's been a lot of speculation as to
what that means for the Xbox brand five
years down the line ten years down the
line what you know that people are you
can coin the term the Xbox Act they want
to see the Xbox app somewhere where that
allows you access to the Xbox ecosystem
wherever it may be on a tablet on a
laptop you know your phone whatever
maybe so again a speculation about how
they're going to actually do that in the
future has led people to kind of say
well are they going to continue making
consoles or are they not gonna make
consoles anymore are they gonna be on
PlayStation are they gonna be on iOS are
they gonna be on Mac um one of the
things that sort of been a running joke
that no one is necessarily talked about
is cloud computing and cloud computing
time running jaws or cloud yeah but even
before that hangar King knows like he
and I were on the front lines of this
computer gaming we will avert one of the
first ones to get that that pre-order
for the online and it was I mean the
idea was this amazing destructible
multiplayer environment and crackdown 3
they're like everything's gonna fall
apart no it seemed crazy it's all
powered by the cloud and it's all
powered by the cloud the game is
releasing if Microsoft is to be believed
in a matter of months where the hell is
the cloud seen it but you know what you
have to do right right what you have to
do is you have to buy Xbox in order to
access you know the cloud is not
accessible by all
I think it's all marketing there is some
reality to it though because the thing
that I've seen especially with what I'm
gonna talk about now is that no one's
actually stopped investing in it and
Kathy it's not one of those technologies
that came out and it was like I know
it's done this was BS completely or
continue to work on it right right so
again like you talked about on live you
talk about NVIDIA GeForce now you talk
about the joking and on the console side
of things the PS now where it's like
yeah I mean they had to do something
with that Gaikai the Hertz because they
made that investments for backward
compatibility gang exactly exactly so
they had to use it now looking at how
Microsoft is looking to do things in the
future
my question is how is is cloud gaming a
viable option an option in addition to
whatever else they're planning right and
the reason I say this is this um this
past week on
Eurogamer our digital foundry Richard
Ledbetter wrote an article about a new
company introducing a cloud gaming
environment this is this is the the
thing that's different from a cloud
gaming service or environment it's
simulating a desktop environment in
which you can do anything that you would
normally do on an actual desktop right
so it's not simulating it's not a game
service it's not it's it's literally you
being able to access a desktop a virtual
desktop that you and you know you pay us
whatever a monthly fee for right and you
can do anything you would do with your
normal desktop at home on a desktop you
can do you can install your steam
account download you know whatever
access your Steam games but all through
the cloud don't you now the thing about
this is what's interesting about this is
the most interesting thing about this is
that the fact that it's it's simulating
that environment and people have been
trying to use like remote desktops and
stuff for years and often times those
remote desktop that is very reliant upon
your connect
and how and you being able to access
your actual computer to him as a tech I
use it all the time you absolutely have
to have you have you have to have a
physical computer this is something you
know you don't need to have a physical
feeder your computer could be completely
in the cloud completely complete access
to Windows 10 so the name of this
company is blade right plan and the name
of the service is shadow yeah the thing
about this it was introduced initially
in France and now it's being introduced
in the UK so basically it is a cloud
gaming service that at this point is
powered let me give you the specs at
this point if being powered by eight
threads from a Xeon processor which
gives you processing power coupling to a
high powered core i7 right okay 12 gigs
of memory 256 gigs of SSD hard drive
space and GPU power that's equivalent to
about a GTX 10 maybe it's pretty
powerful stuff and they're shouting what
they're touting in terms of gaming is
depending on your bandwidth of course
they're touting you know 1080p at nearly
a hundred and fifty frames per second
that's great Wow
4k at 60 frames per second Wow and again
let you know Ledbetter is you know he's
he's tentative he's kind of worried
about what he's hearing right but at the
same time something that that kind of
left a positive impression on him was
the fact that everybody that he spoke to
they seemed very forthcoming about that
that the tech how it works that he
didn't really go into detail in the
article about it right but he did say
that everybody from the top down is so
well-versed on this then it gives him
hope that they're not lying because
online when they came out they gave you
you know it would they gave you
what's a hyperbole the other and
immediately they said no this is not
this this cannot be like the moment you
say there's no lag you know your line
because it's lag anywhere you look at
it's gonna be like so the fact that he
is positive on this he's just waiting to
get
a sort of review copies into Eurogamer
so you can test it out on his own
service and see how hostesses it lends
me to believe that this is a viable
option especially for a company like
Microsoft moving forward that they are
looking into becoming a services based
company they're already doing it on the
windows side we've already talked about
how you know Microsoft Office is a
service now you pay for it and you know
you talk about onedrive and stuff like
that all of this is service based stuff
where you paying a subscription model
Riperton price for for it on a monthly
basis so this stuff is very very
interesting because this if this stuff
holds and in stuff continues to improve
I guarantee you it's gonna be offered as
an option especially for Microsoft I
don't know what what Nintendo does in
the future I don't know a Playstation
does in the future this is something
that we're gonna be seeing in the next
mmm 7 to 10 years as a viable option for
some people who don't want to spend all
that money on that hardware who don't
have the money to spin up either console
hardware a PC hardware right here's
again the catch is that you're
simulating an environment that everybody
uses which is the PC which is go jump in
it I've got my wife the groceries like
that no problem not my daughter
yeah I'm a jumping right quick yeah that
does my only concern I mean my main
thing is um you know obviously image
quality with things like this we got to
see how that you know how that goes
obviously based on how you know the
network and stuff and the cloud stuff
but I mean listen from a potential
standpoint it sounds fantastic
you know it's what I think we're right
now at this point as gamers where it's
kind of like we got to see it to believe
it at this point not that this does oh
right like we they we have to see real
world game application and the key right
now that's why I feel crackdown is it's
really important and you know maybe like
people listen I I didn't meet Lord King
and tell you later god I'll tell you
right now we went to e3 and we said a
crackdown them
like e100 like he did not impress me
just the regular gameplay now that
wasn't using cloud tech that wasn't my
point but the whole point is just the
game itself so but from the multi player
standpoint then they came out in front
of it they said hey you know this is not
reflective of the multi player multi
player is using the destructive
environment is using that cloud tech
into me that's the key for the game I'm
I'm actually purchasing that goo solely
for the multi player because I I'm
getting it from gate pass but I want to
see how that multi player works you know
and along with the coop and stuff like
that because to me if that cuz put it
this way I like you know what the first
time that I kind of touted it was Titan
for one and then when I got it we like
yeah there's AI bots running around but
there was nothing you know revolutionary
that was happening you know I'm saying
so to speak aside from as your servers
powering the networking and making sure
you know it was the driver to our stuff
it's been it's again it's been like
small on a small level I say on the back
end but nothing very groundbreaking just
yet
like I think we need to see something
like crack now if they even just give us
a smidgen of that demo that they show
was it two years ago
you're saying yeah if they do sorry for
interrupting problem if they do pull it
off and we're all pulling for that to
happen because okay I don't care if
you're an ass on the camera Nintendo cam
welcome what camp you're in if cloud
gaming can't get pulled off at what
they're saying it bids well for us as
gamers as a whole
because it now allows these companies to
invest into this technology which will
save us on the other end of buying big
expensive hardware you understand so I'm
pulling for this game to do exactly what
they said when they said and how they
said it because not only will Microsoft
save face which I'm you know a little
bit bias over here what
because you know listen the ribbon that
demeans is gonna be crazy
but that that that forth is Sony and
Nintendo to say you know what let's
start invested in this technology any
smaller companies start to get that look
see like this is this shadow starts to
get the look see maybe Microsoft doesn't
buy shadow maybe Sony does maybe
Nintendo does
could you imagine the switch with the
power of a 1080 kill yourself thing this
is the thing what you the money you save
if this works right if you this
ultimately improves to the point where
works to the point that gamers are happy
with it you understand the amount of
money you save on overhead when you say
I'm not producing the amount of consoles
that I used to write like you know if
you think about packaging shipping
LRD for all that stuff right if you cut
that out of the pipeline pipeline or at
least lessen it and then you have this
as part of your business plan the amount
of money you save and companies are
about making money and saving money
let's not get that twisted okay so it's
a matter likely that King said it's a
matter of viability in the future once
it's viable across the board and they
see it's gonna be hard for anybody to
ignore it no doubt let's get out late
look in on this what do you feel about
the power of the cloud you know I'm just
gonna take a wait-and-see approach on it
you know yeah I'm just gonna take a
wait-and-see approach I want to see what
it can do
how much is this shadow subscription
service about $30 a month this is what I
say like it's not solely it's not solely
a gaming service right it is you have
access so all the games you've purchased
on any other surface that you own
already right so then in a sense its
future proofed because well let's say
you know let's say whatever that service
dies or whatever something
replaces it right you still have all
your games as you've purchased on you
know esteeming whatever that's gonna be
there so it's not like you lose your
games like it on live anything you
purchase on live is gone you nightly
can't access to that anymore right and
then the other thing that makes it kind
of worth it is the fact that again it's
not a gaming service it is you know put
it together it's $30 a month if you have
the year contract right though that it
what it's like the ease of use for a lot
of people matters right if you think
about it right as people like I know
King and somebody who collects stuff
like he hold on to everything right the
thing about it is right all these you
know remasters and stuff notwithstanding
there's a lot of stuff that you own that
you can only access right now if you
plug that old stuff in and get to it
that's the only way you can do it right
right with this the environment is there
for you you're not you're not hold on I
only do it at a cheaper price point
though I want to access at all but I
want to be cheaply accessing it this is
nothing the improvements on the hardware
side yeah they're constantly improving
so whatever newest hardware comes out
they improve on their side and that's an
ultra so it's not like you're gonna
produce at some point in five years
they're not gonna be running a GTX 1080
whatever it is so it's trying to keep up
with time some speed right so you always
want to cut mage phone cut at you it's
always at the start of it again it's a
matter of
people buying into it enough where they
get enough subscriptions where they can
be like okay let's drop the price down
at the start you always gonna eat that
and we know that and everything that we
learn always the first ones in life for
everything right when you put it into
the Microsoft discussion like how we
want that box
yeah but Microsoft is free the reason
why is go cast a shadow on your wallet
they tell you that you gotta sign up for
the year it's $30 a month to do this
stuff right if you gotta tell you all
the great fantastic things that you see
oh oh you want a freelance it you know
you wanna be there no subscription dude
it's $40 a month he's gonna tell you all
the fancy stuff that you do for this $40
what I said was Microsoft said we could
do fancy things to it with the black
cloud is free
No you know people are gonna be I
wouldn't whenever this drops this
amazing cloud you know people can't
argue with my cloud is bigger than your
car you know I just I don't know it's
Donald Trump's are going back and forth
with each other I just think too much
money and if you're interested in those
kinds of aspects you would just build
your own PC and it's like it's still new
so I would I'm definitely waiting and
seeing and gonna see how this shapes up
because it's not sounding very appealing
to me I'd rather just build my own PC
and then upgrade as I go through it like
I mean you can't all the power of money
the probably wanted reference to like in
pertaining to back to console Union like
obviously Microsoft was one the first
kinda it's not a spin your head this
movement so to speak now with crackdown
specifically are you guys at least
curious about the cloud implementation
that's supposed to happen in this
multi-player ladies first
you know since 2014 and they keep
pushing it back clearly there's some
issues going on with the cloud so I'm
not expecting much to be perfectly
honest you think again oh my god thank
you they can't afford to push you back
in they stop complaining it is free damn
I knew chapter one on game pass and does
give you the rest later I have a theory
maybe it may be it's probably not true
but I have a theory that crackdown 3 was
cancelled and then brought back to life
on scale bombs canceled possible but
probably this also probably
about my show cuz remember microsoft
owns all the assets it might show up now
the game passes uh no you're gonna lie
consider all the first party stuff so it
might um the assets might show up in a
different form
anybody know who owns the IP anybody who
no knows who owns you happy but that
doesn't mean they only assets to the
game gotcha okay they purchased the
assets oh good day okay they purchased
the assets to the game and it cancelled
the game Luba gave your answer could you
repeat the question so I gave the best
possible answer in reference to
crackdown 3 specifically in our sleeve
Microsoft spearheading the cloud
movement you know how excited are we
just from the technical standpoint of
the multiplayer implementation like do
you want to see it or does that least
not even excite you in Wally's I don't
have an Xbox so I you know I maybe I'll
have one when it comes out I would like
to get one if my wife would let me have
one you know I have seen this game a
total of encryption wrong I think all of
us have seen the game a total of three
times at the reveal and then we saw it
at e3 last year and it was a it was
mostly Terry Crews and during that
during e3 week we saw that we saw all
those comedians playing it and riffing
on it and I was like this is not how you
show your game yeah that was all this is
not how you show your good one you've
got people who clearly have never played
a game in their lives in three yeah
the physics were awful cars are like
floating in the end and you know people
he's comedian he's unfunny comedians by
the way you're riffing on the game and
like it was like Aaron Greenberg had
like his sad moment the game is
ostensibly coming out in a matter of
months they said it's gonna launch in
spring 2018 spring ends in June so
you've got you've got February
april/may that's four months and I liken
it to that Star Wars or you know so Han
Solo movie I think it's gonna be a
disaster because we have it's coming out
in May we haven't seen hide nor hair of
it we haven't seen a single screenshot
it's the same thing with crackdown 3 I
think you're looking at a 5 out of 10 I
think salvaged it because scalebound got
canceled I think it's going to be I mean
there are other rumors that the
multiplayer is not going to launch with
the game and that's the whole reason
which tells me I agree with Luca that
tells me that there is something wrong
with the cloud and it is not going the
way they wanted it to I'm trusting you
so he says John you think it's me cancel
those like no it's too late for that if
they cancel now that would be a worse
crap storm not swearing yeah crap storm
then if you just killed it again that's
not good
I would agree shout out to prep
crackdown 3 game of the year the baby's
born pretty interesting to me
um obviously as destiny guy and when
Anthony anthem excuse me was a Big Mama
no destiny too much when Adam was
announced um you know it was it was
shown at e3 the trailer look pretty you
know impressive and a lot of people
would call it destiny killer you know it
got a lot of hype behind it obviously
was debuted on the Microsoft stage and
now it's come to find out that it will
not be releasing on 2018 and push back
to 2019 and um yeah clap for that gave
being delayed the hopefully to be
improved and yeah there's gonna be a
besides the realistic time date being
pushed back you know there's a lot going
on right now at the studio and I Jason
Schreyer from kotaku put out a kind of
explosive article right now as far as
referencing what's going on with Bioware
and how pretty much EA I don't say is
pressuring them but there's a lot riding
on success of anthem you know a lot of
the studio's kind of gotten together
they've all stopped on the dragon wars
of
tract was Dragon Age 4 and I believe was
another Star Wars game that those teams
have kind of been pulled off and it's
been kind of all systems go for anthem
just to get that thing out and there was
some comments made about the climate at
the studio right now there's a lot of
pressure they're also upset about some
youtubers publishing kind of negative
information about the game that
supposedly is not true obviously we have
the whole EA inflammatory loot box
you know craze going on right now or
people are upset with yeah their concern
because it's you know under a ship that
you know something might go home the
roundtable obviously you know I lost
podcasters he started off as a destiny
podcast and I would never guess a lot of
interest to us and I just think that
anthem can avoid the mistakes that
destiny is currently making right now so
you know destiny community's very upset
you know so I want to bring this too
late look I don't I don't catch you as a
person who plays destiny often Hollow
hey let's go so my question to you is
one how excited you were about anthem
initially and then to now with these
news of the delay and possible things
going on in the studio as far as
pressure what do you think of all this
well I definitely think that they're
scrambling
I think battlefront to have bad press
killed them it killed them and I think
anthem had a bunch of loot boxes and all
that stuff in it and they're like oh we
got to pull this back we got to take
this out we integrated this into the
game we can't have this we cannot suffer
another blow it's like after Andromeda
and then battlefront 2 I'm like it's
looking a little it's looking a little
bad over there it's a little spooky guys
so I'm hoping the game comes out and
it's good its well-received but it's
just like man
sucks cuz I love Bioware you know what I
mean it really really sucks that they
went to the UM the devil that is jumping
on your point cuz I'm in the same boat
as you cuz you I'm you're you're a Mass
Effect girl I'm master guy like that
that's my baby and when I heard Casey
Hudson that's the guy like that that's
Mass Effect that's the glory is not in
trauma two we gonna act like that it
happen because that's not him I don't
think that day is a very good point and
people are even seeing this Lord
negative that the success of anthem is
so important that Bioware might not
exist if distinct oh no dude no I agree
if this is a failure that could be
catastrophic for provider because Dragon
Age doesn't have it's a great series I
know the creative will deform creative
director of Dragon Age Mike Laidlaw he's
not with Bioware he's a good guy but
Dragon Age doesn't have the household
poll that the name Mass Effect doesn't
anymore but you know to look people are
earth people are willing to overlook bad
reviews and flaws because of because of
a brand look at what happened with
battlefront - I agree with Luke in the
sense that yeah it killed him initially
but if you look at sales at battlefront
- after that and you didn't when the
movie came out like it was it was a huge
spike it still ended up in the one of
the it was like the number five I think
of the top Ellis Emily gives the year so
a lot of people buy a lot of people are
playing it because it's got its Star
Wars that people are going to buy it um
there is a lot of hype around anthem
there is a lot of interest around anthem
because this is the 18 so to speak but
there's also a lot of there's a lot of
doubt I mean you asked um can Bioware
not repeat can they escape the problems
or the mistakes that destiny made or
bunch of its destiny - they can the real
question is is will it yeah um and with
EA in the mix I just don't know I mean
it's all gonna come down to whether or
not they learn the lesson don't talk to
them from battlefront - and also look at
write down the look if anybody from EA
is listening to this or by where write
down a list of everything bunch you did
it that's new - and eggs don't do it
he made a good point he said it all
started with them releasing Titan in
battle for m4 battlefield right within
weeks of each other they made that
mistake and they thought that burn IPs
would be as strong as they are maybe
they get that too what's the word I
think they respond so they could that's
that's a little too conceited for me I
will say that I think was overconfident
the IP well not only is it you know
participating in titanfall moments very
well-received but nowhere on multiple
platforms right and and the game was
sent out to die like they took that
thing I buy in the shed and put a bowl
of the back of its head and you know I
and you know somebody said oh well
Microsoft was intentionally you know
sabotaging Rises the Tomb Raider
releasing on CBS Fallout 4 I'm like no
that's just a that's just an idiotic
decision to and I think it's the same
thing with EA I think I don't think they
were trying to lessen the respawn or the
value of respond but I mean who knows
you know I mean maybe you're right but I
just I think everybody can be concerned
because EA as Luke this pointed out it
has taught they do not have a track
record of what I would call measure does
eliminating industry you know what they
do they buy good developers right and
then they make they force them to do
these just shitty consumer anti-consumer
practices and then when the game doesn't
do well they're like oh you messed up
I'm gonna close you down you know I
really like Dragon Age Inquisition but I
like Dragon Age Inquisition a lot so I'm
I'm kind of worried about the next
dragon age but for Andromeda there are
signs that the game wasn't doing well
because people kept leaving well not
only that but we didn't see it
exactly
I mean I mean the first demo we saw of
it and it was like what seven months
before the game launched what what was
was the main character running through
an empty hallway and then I was like and
that was it I was like wha they look
like it was squat running yeah you know
that Bioware run you don't you know
we're ready and it's 20 wheat that's all
the topic every one of these characters
has a different run like like like
Rockstar their characters run weird yeah
but um but he was running like he was
holding a huge demo ended and I was like
okay this game is in trouble cuz this
was in trouble and and it was so bad it
was so bad the fall it was so bad that
it killed the Mass Effect franchise like
if you love and I love Mass Effect 2 is
when the message is my favorite game
ever in the history of the medium and
this is how the series ended not with a
bang but with a whimper and and the
exact same fate is waiting for by where
if anthem is not a massive success and
it needs to be a massive success the bus
I saw them run inside anthem and it
didn't look like dumpy run so I'm like
people are saying oh this is the destiny
killer I'm like look people will come
back to destiny too they will and the
most controversial statement you've made
since you know like people will connect
to destiny to look people people came
back and droves for the taken king they
came back in droves became ever
battlefront you know double nickel I
think they need you I think they need to
ya and they keep like messing up every
update they come out if they break
something else and it's it almost makes
me think like they're deliberately
sabotaging their game because they just
don't
it's that PC version of destiny then it
opened up a whole can of underbelly and
get into the underbelly of that game and
be able to like - because otherwise like
I'm here in the console side
you're not knowingly valishia using
ratios about this love so maybe they
might be scratching ahead as a wider PC
I thought everybody the same thing once
this PC community gets a whole year game
when they start ripping it up and
finding out what's your cheat net oh we
didn't know they was throwing to get you
imagine this right destiny one and let
these guys get a hold of the cold of
destiny one and tell us all the things
that we did not know that we thought was
good for us you know like you never
really understand this this that
conspiracy part of it I would have never
released a PC game leasing these codes
man shouting elephant mates native thank
you for the support really appreciate I
want to get solving I know he's gonna
look quite as far as specifically um
what I have in terms of anthem we have
to remember that Bioware is not the
company that it once was like the
leadership is different I can part from
Casey Hudson but yeah but the doctors
the doctors are not there the doctors
not in the house anymore it's different
and again the influence of VA is evident
and they're very few developers in this
day and age that are just that are not
one bad game away from being shut down
or having massive layoffs
I mean Naughty Dog it's probably one of
the few that I could just think of that
they can they can have a soso game or an
outright flop and then they might be
okay they just mend it and that's just
Wow so it's one of those things where
it's scary to me that they have to
scramble it's so hard to make sure that
anthem is where it needs to be and
you're doing it at the expense of what
Dragon Age has to be as well like I mean
like negative said it doesn't have the
name recognition that's something like
an anthem at this point does because
they've compared it sold so much the
destiny and Destiny such a big thing and
I and Dragon Age although they've said
something about it being a living world
and I don't know what that means living
world that's what they all right it's a
living world or the world you can pause
and walk out the room as you're gonna
die oh it's scary to me that they had
that all hands have to be on deck for
this game and and and the the future of
the the developer is so tied to this one
thing so it you know because it's an
insane amount of pressure to be working
under put out a good product and in
addition to be worried about your
livelihood at the same time everything
and and the snitches are going to Jason
Schreyer saying that they are feeling
that pressure yeah that's the thing that
really bugs me you know is that not just
talking my Bioware but Bioware Bungie
you know respawn with titanfall 2 oh
it's it's hard enough in the I mean
triple-a development is tough I mean
people put in 1890 our weeks there are
magnificent families and and it's bad
enough for these people what having
their games pulled apart and dissected
and discussed but what's even worse is
the the crap they put up with on social
media and all acts forums and so which
is why I tried to temper my criticisms
of destiny to and by where I'm not gonna
sit here and tell you oh by where I hope
you go down loot boxes yeah because
these I mean you know these are still
these are companies with men who have a
man and women who have families and
they're looking they're working hard to
do what they can to deliver do a decent
product um and I think that's something
have conversations like this that gets
lost
you know what absolutely and that's the
human element and that's a good point
you make it a great point I mean there's
a lot of Prezi these are people with
lives and and you know if this studio
closes you know like I said think of the
history and I think what would be lost
and no mass effect like no matter what
no matter what happens this it could it
could be Mass Effect 2 online right like
which would be amazing even if it's Mass
Effect 2 online if it's better than that
you know there will be a group of people
out there that it's not good enough it's
not good enough for them sources yeah
their brothers have their perspective
that every game environment must be a
mile model world where it's candy and
everybody's giving out marshmallows
listen I want all hands on deck I want
you to stop what you're doing over there
I want you to stop I want you to get
over here this game has to be a success
or your fire do you understand this this
is what I want you to understand and
this is the environment I want you to
work under if you cannot work under this
environment you're not the best of the
best you need to leave I want you to
work under this pressure because the
last games that y'all put outs up we
can't have this is the thing though
that's a reality that happens any work
environment the problem is like that the
issues the issues that have that have
caused them to be in this position are
not necessarily the developers fault
right right we know this to be fact or
is this something that we're speculating
on nine times out of ten if you look at
these situations especially with big
corporations like like it like an ear
and Activision right they have they're
not the ones that are gonna let you go
or just do whatever you want they're
gonna have a hand in everything you're
doing all this loot crate stuff and this
is really from the top this is they're
looking at your front your your artistic
product and looking at how to monetize
it just playing that's what you're
supposed to do as a company and we keep
looking at these people as evil and this
and
trying to keep the company afloat and
make money is why I jump in looking like
I understand and it's a business but my
thing is once that starts affecting the
creative process and it's like cuz look
at what's going on with destiny that's
why I brought this topic up it was so
concerning to me because I'm like they
came out with destiny too and literally
did an about-face on all the things or
systems that were in place their people
loved about this like when used to play
a strike or whatever would have been you
would get rare gear now that stuff is
like behind every verse right you don't
say and then it was like ships and [ __ ]
like I don't ever first thing I think is
well you don't want that in anthem you
don't want all these bad things that
you've been dealing with you want anthem
to beat the purists second coming it's
gonna be a game that's gonna come out
and it's gonna have his floors and it's
gonna have to grow will we allow it to
grow these people are allowing things to
grow that day they're killing it while
it's still being born
I remember the anticipation for certain
games before when we used to regain
throw a magazine or egm and we'll be OHS
apeun it this this time of tiki torches
these guys are out here and they're
burning our stuff before we get a chance
to touch it I agree with that completely
all I'm saying is in charcoal or Sam
Toby the chat is we get we can't ignore
the elephant in the room with ei as far
as their reputation for killing storming
well this gladiator business if you're
not performing well you're executed
goodbye and you boys adore you and we're
gonna poach your best guys on the
on another team consider the fact what
if Luca was right if that was the kid to
be honest me I don't I doubt it but I
wouldn't put it past ei to do something
like that
that's that's awful feel they can avoid
these mistakes what's your final take on
it you want that hat take well um you
know it's kind of hard not to mess up
like destiny to is messing up in my
opinion it's pretty pretty clear what
they're doing is wrong and what they're
doing wrong I'm like I said I'm worried
but I just want it to be a good game you
know as long as it's a good game good
mechanics and a good story and it works
I I think it'll be fine and it's just
kind of like you know you just got to
keep in mind that at the end of the day
these corporations the only thing they
care about is getting our money and
whatever disruption they have to put out
put forth to get that they're gonna do
it enough
that's the Animus what I got wrap this
thing up soon so um obviously we have a
new ILP poll this week so on obviously
with our good friends the Austrian
retailer those following the recent Xbox
game past announcement do you think this
will have a negative trickle-down effect
on retail answers are a yes game past
threatens physical and retail markets be
no complete overreaction to the future
of digital gaming or see I don't care
i'm getting game pass to beat them
exclusives and unsubscribe lady lucca an
absolute pleasure to have you in the
building where can the fire find you I
just want to say thank you so much for
having me I had a great time and I'm
definitely down to come back whenever
you guys want
you're coming back yeah but you guys can
find me at the ash in Lucca on Twitter
in Xbox Live you can find me at Lucy
Quinn on PSN um I have a youtube channel
now so if you look up the ash and Luke
are you just go to my Twitter the link
is in the description there and you can
also find me on the RDX podcast that's
Tuesdays at 8 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
on dealer getting the shadow and Thank
You absolute pleasure love what you're
doing out here please subscribe to our
channel she has some great there's no
topic that's not touched let's just say
that she goes love it I love the passion
great follow on Twitter and also good
friends that are RDX you know she lays
it down very passionate in this
community like to see what you're doing
out there so it's a pleasure to have
course we will have you back now we got
my man love- with the guest of Paris to
do challenge has arrived tell us what's
going on in a week and a five people
find you well just for Enrique in chat
I'll give you I'll do it like a little
little Christopher Walken for you let's
go let's go come on I'll give you guys I
used to do that I would do that but like
like do lines from games like Kratos you
know it's amazing what you got you got
to get me the Plaza Hotel I'm Britain
with me the destruction see and also
please go and subscribe to our you which
channel which is where we do the
majority of our podcasts and streaming
now that is yet twitch.tv slash official
SDG see we would really appreciate it
they had Chanel beyond just that yep
Shinobi's actually he's a really good
friend of mine and we we got the we got
just joined wushu studios and really
really excited for him I knew it was
coming like a couple weeks before I
couldn't see anything but you can also
you'll be able to find Apaches
this would be the second Pepsi stand
roller is where we get our media
credentials and you'll be able to find
me on a couple of panels that I can't
talk about you eyes but I am very
excited to finally reveal those when
when the time is right but arms yeah and
uh yeah that's it awesome like I said
keep doing what you're doing we like
what SDG see is going you growing out
here moving please subscribe to twitch
that is their new home like I said great
show and again lot of Industry Nuggets
and if you want to learn how things
actually work please pay attention to
the SDG see great group of guys so of
course we got to use your suspects we're
gonna wrap this thing up glad to have
you back this week intro music is always
the second female to be on our show but
it's always fantastic to see more women
involved in the car you can find me on
at Lord saw bio P on Twitter and being
sovereign on both PSN and absolutely the
premium gamer lord King hits now I can
finally find you I would like to say
thank you to our esteemed guest for
showing up lady Lucca thank you for
showing up it was a great show even the
pre-chat was fantastic and my man
Deadpool
I don't care what anybody say I swear to
God the first time I've ever seen him I
thought I thought we had Ryan rebels on
the show Thank You ppreciate is
fantastic I love the banter between us
and it is it was a great show um you can
catch me on Twitter you know just go to
ILP and you know find me up in there
King David OTW I'm right up in there and
uh Facebook and Instagram you know you
know guys um we appreciate everything we
appreciate the chat I oh man it was
fantastic today chat is lit listen if
you don't at me in the chat I'm looking
at stuff scroll up be honest sometimes I
might dive inside but you know get at me
in a chat and I'll definitely respond
back to you but thank you guys and
everybody for showing up it was a great
show Gaming realness was spread we had
to tell you which now what you wanted to
hear but what you needed to hear again
thank you for the guests amazing the
Ashton Luka and mr. negative awesome as
well make sure you hit that like
subscribe to all the inner circle
Network media outlets we got the
multi-verse up tomorrow also the iron
law podcast on audio will be going up on
iTunes and SoundCloud please subscribe
please hit a little review if you can
would be much appreciated we're out here
trying to put good content out here in
the community so it's about 3 o'clock
now everybody needs to enjoy their day
have a good time and we'll catch you on
the next one bye